Russia has massed military
forces on Ukraine’s borders.
But Putin denies he’ll invade. His demands are
about much more than Ukraine. What’s going on?
Putin is holding Ukraine hostage. He
demands NATO never expand to the east.
That NATO pull its military forces from
members that joined after the Cold War.
And that NATO never deploy certain
weapons near Russia’s borders.
In return, he promises…nothing.
Putin wants to regain control of Ukraine of
course. But, more than that, he wants to destroy
NATO. He wants to divide east European members
from their west European allies. To split the US
from Europe. To regain Russian hegemony. Those
are his real goals in this manufactured crisis.
The US must stand by its alliance commitments. It
must stand with Ukraine. It must stand with NATO.
If we give in to Putin’s demands, it will be open
season for aggressive dictators around the world.
It will be disastrous for America.
Do you think the US should stand up to Putin? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.